i want to get into a little bit of of
spoiler territory but
um kaylee you have a very iconic scene
at the end here with
a very iconic person for rusa bulk
how did you react when you found out
that you are in fact the legacy
i mean that twist i didn't get that info
until after i had booked the rule i
think
that was really under lock and key that
that um information um it was a total
twist for me
when i read it in the script and i knew
that fans were
gonna i just can imagine that moment
and watching fans on it being on the
screen and then you see her face and i
can just hear
everyone just like screaming because
that's how i was like when i read it
um yeah but also uh very
uh and intimidating to
to then understand that that's how it
all um
that's the big reveal that um we had to
keep under lock and key um but
she's she was so great to me
she i mean she's a total icon and i was
um
at the very end of filming she like
looked at me and she took me by the
shoulders and she's like
you are great the film is yours now
and it was like the craft had been taken
you know
she like passed the torch it was very
overwhelming and emotional
i love that because you never i mean
sometimes people you know when their
their things get rebooted they don't
like it necessarily so to
hear that is is awesome very supportive
yeah
well it was a just a total dream of mine
because
uh she is my supreme she
she truly is like so iconic to me and i
think she is
um such an undervalued um heavyweight
when it comes to the world of acting um
she is her performance in the original
craft is
um is so unbelievable uh so so i
fangirled out
really hard when i when i met her
um and she is truly one of the most
gracious and generous
people um i've met and and
i was just so um honored that she
that she was willing to be a part of
this and come on this journey with me
there's a lot of like setup in the end
and i'm wondering
fun cameo or do you have something in
mind
going forward
you know i think in in writing this
script i always had
a continuation in mind that would um
that would follow it
so um we'll see we'll see we'll see what
happens
we have my producer who's on this call
to is a huge craft fan
we were just texting each other all
kinds of questions we're like do you
think skeet is the baby daddy and i'm
like i don't know if the timeline adds
up
no i need a sequel
oh well you know from your mouth to
sony's ears
right right i think it's gonna happen i
have a good feeling
me too i won't yeah i have thought it
was gonna happen since i first read the
script
and i want it to happen so it probably
will happen because i want it to happen
so did you um did you toy with getting
you know any of the other
girls to to come make a cameo um
i i met with each of the original uh
covered members which was just
so exciting again for me as a fan
and they're all so lovely um and
and just wonderful human beings so um
so yeah i think you know i just wanted
to make sure that i had everyone's
blessing and
and um and i think in the future it
would be really cool to
um you know have an inter
intergenerational storyline
so um yeah that's what i'll say
be careful a lot of weirdos out here we
are the weirdos mister
[Music]